The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So when we talked
about learning, we said that
everything we know comes from
learning except that which is
given to us by our genes.
Our knowledge of how to walk
around in the world, to read,
to think, to talk, to feel, the
values that we have, the
hopes we have, the fears we
have, they're all learned
through experience.
And then we talked about another
approach to thinking
about how we learn things
through memory, and today I'm
going to talk about what we
understand to be the brain
organization of human memory.
And Oliver Sacks, in The Lost
Mariner, chapter 2, talks
about one of the two major kinds
of amnesia, the loss of
memory due to a brain disorder
or a brain injury.
But he has a very nice language
from Luis Bunuel
talking about memory. "You
have begun to lose your
memory, if only in bits and
pieces, to realize that memory
is what makes our life.
Life without memory
is no life at all.
Our memories, our coherence, our
reason, our feeling, even
our action.
Without it, we are nothing.
I can only wait for the final
amnesia, the one that erases
an entire life as it did
my mother's." Right?
So our memories of our lives,
what we've done, where we've
been, what mattered to us--
that's a huge piece
of who we are.
And he runs into a patient who
came into the hospital early
in 1975 with a note saying
"Helpless, demented, confused,
and disoriented." He
had what we call
clinically Korsakoff's Syndrome.
So these are individuals who
have severe alcoholism for
many years, and a subset of
those people develop a severe
memory disorder,
like this man.
He's 49 years old.
He tells Sacks about his life,
details of his life, going
into World War II, that
he worked on a
submarine, and so on.
And Sacks says, "a full and
interesting life remembered
visually in detail, but for some
reason his memories stop
around World War II."
Then he asked him,
what year is it?
Remember the year is 1975.
And he says, it's 1945.
What do you mean?
We've won the war, FDR--
Franklin Delano Roosevelt-- is
dead, Truman's at the helm.
These are great times ahead.
And Jimmy, how old
would you be?
He stopped and he said,
well, I guess I'm 19.
That would have been his age,
you know, 20 years ago, right?
30 years ago.
So he's stuck in time.
He thinks it's historically
a while ago.
He has the completely
wrong age.
And Sacks takes out a mirror and
throws it at him and says,
what do you--
what happened?
And he says, Jesus Christ,
what's going on?
What happened?
Is this a nightmare?
Am I crazy?
Is this a joke?
So it's as if he's lost the
last 30 years of his life.
And he's living as if it
were 30 years ago.
And then when he walks back in,
he's hardly recognized.
Sacks is hardly recognized
by the person.
On intelligence, he shows
excellent ability, but his
memory-- very quickly,
he forgets things.
What is this, I asked him,
showing him a photo in a
magazine I was holding.
It's the moon.
No it's not, if it's a
picture of the Earth
taken from the moon.
I'm mean, don't forget, in 1945,
nobody imagined that we
would be sending up people
to the moon, right?
And taking pictures from
the moon of the Earth.
You're used to it.
It's nothing to you.
No it's not.
It's a picture of the Earth
taken from the moon.
Doc, you're kidding.
Somebody would have to get
a camera up there.
Naturally.
Hell, you're joking.
How would you know that?
So he has lost the last 30 years
of his life, for all
practical purposes,
despite normal
intelligence and normal thought.
So we're going to talk more
about how this occurs in
another patient, and more
generally, how the brain
supports your ability
to learn things.
So here's this remarkable
brain.
And in one sense, you could say
it's almost all there to
absorb things in life.
You have very small insects
that can do a lot with the
genes they're given.
We have big brains to learn
the life we lead.
And I'm going to come back at
the end to this metaphor, but
the idea that in many ways, your
brain as you sit there
right now, or any healthy
brain, is kind of like a
symphony orchestra that has many
specialized instruments
for learning different
kinds of things.
And you feel like a unified
whole, and you are, and these
instruments interact
with each other.
But just like a symphony
orchestra, you know, together
they make a sound.
So imagine you're a Martian who
lands outside a symphony
hall, and you hear a
symphony playing.
It's something beautiful.
It sounds really interesting.
If you're a Martian on the
outside of the symphony hall,
how many instruments are you
guessing, how many things
might you guess, are
making that sound?
Would you have any idea?
One big one?
Two big ones?
50?
It'd be very hard to guess.
And it's only been in the last
20 years or so that we had
some real clarification
on the instruments of
learning in our brains.
So I'm going to talk about
three things today.
Anterograde amnesia, the loss
of the ability to form new
memories; retrograde amnesia,
the loss of memories you
already had; and that idea of
memory systems, this idea that
each of us has a symphony of
learning instruments in our
brain that empowers us to learn
different kinds of things.
So anterograde amnesia is,
again, the inability to
remember new information.
And people mostly talk about
two kinds, but as you see,
they're most of life, OK?
Not all of that-- we'll talk
about that-- but a lot of it,
such as events you experience
or facts you encounter.
So think about this.
All the events you've remembered
from your entire
life, all the facts you ever
learned in school, at home, on
the computer--
that's a huge amount
of what you know.
And a patient like we just
described or the patients I'll
describe in a moment lose the
ability to remember any event
from the day they become amnesic
or remember much in
the way of new information
of any kind, in terms of
facts of the world.
So in what sense is memory
in the brain
distributed or localized?
In what sense is it in one
place or many places?
And this has been a central
debate in all of neuroscience,
but in memory, too.
And Karl Lashley, a giant of
neuroscience, who worked just
two T stops away at Harvard,
said this: "It is not possible
to demonstrate the isolated
localization of a memory trace
anywhere in the nervous
system.
The engram is represented
throughout the brain." The
engram's kind of a magic word
in memory and the brain.
The engram is the thing in you
that changes in your brain
that is the stuff of a memory.
If you learn today that there's
more terrible news in
Japan with the nuclear reactors,
and you remember
that because it matters to you,
because you care about
the people, there's a physical
change in your brain that is
the memory.
If you remember what I'm saying
now for more than a few
moments, that is a physical
change in your brain.
So all of us in neuroscience
are amazed by that.
How can we physically change the
brain to be the biological
record of a memory,
that we can keep
and use in the future?
And the engram, Karl Lashley
said, is represented
throughout the brain.
It's spread throughout
the brain.
Here's why he thought that.
So he was working with rats,
and they ran a maze.
And you saw how quickly you
learned the maze to go from
start to finish to get the
food if you're a rat.
And here's what he found, and
the results won't amaze you,
to start with.
So what he did is he made--
this is number of errors
during learning, so
it's good to be low.
And this is how much neocortex
they took out, ranging from
10% to 80%.
And he discovered that the more
neocortex you took out,
the worse learner you were.
Now if it didn't happen in some
broad sense, we'd say,
well, what part of us
is learning it?
You take out more brain, you're
less of a good reader.
10% out, 10% percent
bad memory.
50% of brain out, 50%
of bad memory.
80% of the brain out, 80%
bad memory, right?
OK, that makes sense.
But what he was really impressed
by is it didn't seem
to him to matter where he took
the brain out of the rat.
It just didn't matter.
It's just the percent
that he took out.
Whatever percent he took
out is how bad
the learner you were.
And we'll come back to that, but
that's why I said, it must
be spread everywhere, because
wherever I take out brain,
part of the memory is weakened
or disappears.
And sometimes people call that
mass action for distributed
memory, that's spread
throughout the brain
in this mass way.
It's just spread all
over the place.
And a single clinical case--
I'll spend a few moments
on him for two reasons.
It is the historical case that
turned this around, and I have
a particular perspective on
this because when I was a
graduate student, I did a lot
of work with this single
patient whose case turned around
our understanding of
the mammalian brain
and memory.
So as I start to
talk about it--
I can't tell you what Phineas
Gage was really like, beyond
what I read, OK?
Or Broca's patients
from the 1900s.
I can tell you what HM, the man
we're about to talk about,
was like because I spent many,
many hours with him, two
blocks from here, when I was a
graduate student in Suzanne
Corkin's lab.
So the structure we'll focus
on is something called the
hippocampus.
It looks sort of big
in the picture.
It's about the size of about 2/3
of your thumb, one on the
left and one on the right in the
insides of the medial part
of the temporal lobes.
A pretty small percentage
of the brain.
And you can see it's
located here.
Here it is sort of drawn out.
And here's the story
of this man.
He died a couple years ago.
There's lots of plays and movies
and books in the works.
I can also tell you that when I
was a graduate student here,
my fellow graduate students
would say, tell us who HM,
what his initials really stand
for, as if it really mattered,
particularly.
But I felt privileged to have
the secret knowledge of what
his name was.
When he died, they
published it.
Everybody knows now, so
my secret is out.
Or our secret is out.
He was born in 1926.
At age 16 he had his first
major epileptic seizure.
By age 27, he was having many,
many seizures a day.
You can have petit mal seizures,
where you tune out
from the world.
You can have grand mal seizures
that lead to physical
convulsions.
By age 27, the medications were
not helping him, in 1953,
very much, that were
available.
And he was just sitting in his
house just waiting for the
next seizure, basically.
That was his life.
He was a man of normal
intelligence and fairly
typical, average background.
Nothing remarkable.
And in order to treat the
epilepsy, William Scoville,
the surgeon, resected, or took
out surgically, the tissue.
Here's this cartoon of
what he took out--
the hippocampus, also the
amygdala just in front of it,
also tissue that surrounds it.
And the reason he took it out
is the single most likely
place where epileptic seizures
start is the hippocampus.
It's kind of a signal, in many
ways, that the hippocampus
does something very dangerous.
It's operating in some sort
of fast speed lane of
neurobiology.
It's a very sensitive part of
the brain, for lack of oxygen,
for diseases.
We'll talk about Alzheimer's
today.
It's a very vulnerable part
of the brain, but it does
something magical and essential
for memory.
And so they couldn't locate
where the seizures were
starting, very well, from him in
ways they typically do, so
they said, OK.
He has all these seizures.
We don't know what to do.
Let's take out the left and the
right hippocampus and the
surrounding tissue.
And in terms of seizure
control, it was pretty
successful.
He had to stay on medications
from that day 'til a few years
ago, when he passed away.
But he had very, very
few seizures
compared to before that.
So it was medically
very successful in
terms of seizure control.
It had a giant side effect.
From that day 'til a couple
years ago, HM never formed a
new memory for any event, or
for all practical purposes,
for any fact that he was exposed
to ever again, despite
his normal intelligence and his
otherwise intact abilities.
So they took an MR of HM.
It took a long time to decide
they could even take a MR
picture of HM, because they were
very worried that if you
put him in a MR scanner, there's
magnetic fields, and
often they put in clips
after surgery.
Regularly they put in clips
after surgery, to keep the
vessels from bleeding.
And they weren't sure
what the clips were
made of for a while.
And so they said, well, we can't
put him in, because we
could move the clips and kill
him, which would be bad.
So they thought it
was dangerous.
And they did a huge detective
process of going to factory
that made them and talking to
people who built it before
they decided-- it took, like, 10
years of research to decide
that the clips were not metal
and they could take an MR.
And even here-- here's the top
of the brain, normal person.
Here's the hippocampus, the
small structure in you--
pretty small.
It's removed in him, but you
can see he's got a lot of
brain left, except for these
removed structures.
But what happened was he had
such a fantastic impairment of
learning new information,
it got the
label of a global amnesia.
Global amnesia.
It didn't matter whether tests
were hard, like remembering
stuff or multiple choice.
He failed practically every
standard test of memory you'd
ever give a person.
Or if it's words or nonsense
syllables, faces, clicks,
mazes, public events,
assassinations of presidents,
wars, going to the
moon, whatever
you think of as famous--
he didn't know they
happened at all.
Personal events.
The death of his own parents.
If you asked him how his parents
were doing, he would
say something like, I haven't
seen them for a while.
He would not know they
had passed away.
So no matter how publicly
famous something was, no
matter how personally important
it was, that
knowledge--
he could remember it for a few
seconds, and we'll talk about
that more, but it
would drift away
completely within seconds.
No matter how often he heard it,
no matter how personally
important it was.
And you could say, what does he
say his experience is like?
So Brenda Milner, the
neuropsychologist, who did a
lot of the critical original
research with him, describing
his case said that he's said,
"Every day is alone in itself,
whatever joy I've had and
whatever sorrow I've had." I
mean, it sounds very poetic, and
it's true, except that for
HM, his memory lasts seconds.
So he doesn't remember any day
since 1950 or something.
So I think his experience is
more like this. "Right now I'm
wondering, Have I done or
said anything amiss?
You see, at this moment,
everything looks clear to me."
His mind is clear.
He's smart.
"But what happened just before?"
What happened a
minute ago, or two minutes
ago, or five minutes ago?
"That's what worries me.
It's like waking from a
dream; I just don't
remember." All right?
So when we worked with him here,
a few blocks from here,
he wouldn't know who I was.
He wouldn't know why
he was here.
He was an extremely pleasant
and wonderful research
participant.
A piece of that was-- he was
very nice and very pleasant.
A piece of that was he didn't
know time was passing.
So if any of you are involved
in experiments as
participants, sometimes people
enjoy the experiment for about
five minutes but not for the
next 55, because they're
getting a lot of measurements
to get a good measurement.
For HM, it was never an
hour-long experiment.
It was always a minute and
a half experiment.
So you had to be very careful
not to abuse that situation as
a researcher.
So here's his name,
Henry Molaison.
Here's his pictures from his
youth and from this.
But you see how he had
a complete reversal?
All of a sudden, the removal
just two small regions-- the
left and the right hippocampus
in the brain--
stopped the creation, of
formation of new memories
altogether and in any
practical way.
So that shows you that memory's
not spread throughout
the brain in a sort of
undifferentiated mass-action
way, but that particular parts
of the brain play very
particular roles in how
memories are formed.
And the hippocampus plays
a huge role in that.
Can't see it.
So they had a big project where
they brought him from
the nursing home in Connecticut
where he was.
They drove him by ambulance to
Massachusetts General Hospital.
They overnight did a something
like an eight hour MRI scan on
him, to have the world's most
detailed MRI scan you
practically have on anybody.
And then they removed his
brain and sent it to a
laboratory in San Diego, where
they took his brain and they
sliced it into many, many, many
incredibly thin slices
that they're going to
post on the web.
And on the web for quite
a while was the
slicing of his brain.
He consented to this, all this
research effort, and finally
his brain is a gift to research
and understanding the
brain and memory.
So let me tell you a couple of
experimental results from him,
and then you might think of
questions you have about what
a man like this is like, OK?
So we talked about last time
about that if you give a list
of words to people, and you try
to do it yourself, that
people remember the
first words best--
the primacy effect, a long-term
memory effect that's
not affected by adding a
few seconds of delay--
and a recency affect--
superior memory for the last few
words of the list that's
strongly affected by adding in
just 10 seconds of delay from
the last word until
you recall.
And this is done with other
amnesic patients, and not HM,
but a similar disorder.
You can see that their memory
is worse overall--
there, the dark line--
but they have some
benefit from the
beginning of the list and--
but it's small.
It's not the same
as the control--
but they're completely normal,
completely normal for the last
two or three words.
So this is what we mean by
impaired long-term memory and
spared short-term memory.
But the short-term memory's
just moments.
But it's not just an impression
you have.
It's a scientific experiment
you can do.
Here's another--
we did this last time.
We said, if you read digits to
people and ask them to repeat
them back aloud, that we have a
limited short-term memory of
seven plus or minus two.
People get to about seven
or eight, typically.
So there's a mean test that's
given to look at something.
So here's what they do.
Imagine that you do this test,
and you were correct for two
digits, correct for three,
repeating them back after you
heard them.
Four, five, six, seven,
you did well.
And then you made mistakes at
eight, which would be very
typical for a human.
So your span, therefore,
is seven.
That's how much you can hold
in short-term memory.
It varies a little bit from
person to person.
And now they're going to do all
the rest of the experiment
at one beyond your span.
One beyond what you can do.
One beyond what your
short-term memory--
here's the limit of your
short-term memory.
Let's add one thing.
And one thing that we know helps
memory is repetition.
It's not the best way to learn
things, but it is a powerful
way to learn things.
So now they give the entire
experiment with eight digits
at a time for this person, one
beyond what you could report.
So they give you this, and
they give you this.
But they give you one boost,
which is every third one, it's
the same sequence over
and over again.
So some you hear once
and once only.
And one, you hear over
and over again.
Is that OK?
Now what would happen if you
think, if you hear eight
digits over and over again?
What would happen?
You know this in
your own life.
Your Social Security number,
telephone numbers, things--
what happens?
Can you learn eight digits
if you do it over and--?
Yeah.
It wouldn't be easy, but you
get it with repetition.
So here's what happens
in typical people.
Here's the repetition.
Here's how well they do for the
non-repeated super-span ones.
They never get that
good because they
basically can't do that.
Occasionally they get lucky,
but mostly not.
But the ones that repeat, they
get better and better.
So repetition is another way
to break the bounds of
short-term memory and register
something in long-term memory.
But in HM, they did this for
hundreds of trials, and he
never got better at the
repeated series.
So you could do endless
repetition with him, or it
could be personally important.
He wouldn't remember it.
So let me add one more
piece to the story.
If I talk to you and say, here
are the digits, tell that back
to me, that's an auditory-verbal
experiment.
So they're words, and
you're hearing them.
You can also test short-term
memory and long-term memory
using a visuo-spatial
test of blocks.
So you're seeing what the
examiner sees, with numbers on
the back of each of these.
The person taking the test
just sees these blocks as
black boxes without
any number.
You need that because you have
a piece of paper with numbers
on it that tell you
what to tap.
OK?
So when you give this test,
you might see five, seven,
eight, and you would tap with
your hand, five, seven, eight,
and the person would
tap that back.
And I can tell you what made me
pretty nervous when I gave
this test to a person
who had a long one?
Because I'd have to read the
numbers, practice it, and I'd
be desperately trying to get
eight my head, which I could
barely do, maybe.
Because I could tap eight back,
so if a person was--
and then we'd do
the same thing.
We'd say, if you can do eight,
we'll test you at nine and
repeat them.
And here's two findings,
and let's talk
about HM for a moment.
So one finding is now, in
patients now-- we're going to
switch one thing a little bit.
HM had the left and the right
hippocampus removed.
In these patients, they
had either the left
or the right removed.
Either the left or the right.
So here's what happens for
normal controls, for the
numbers that are beyond
their span.
Not too good, low performance,
but they benefit from
repetition.
Here's what happens for the
patients with left hippocampal
removals for the
auditory-verbal
things for the digits.
So they're good for immediate
memory for this stuff, but
they're terrible at developing
a long-term memory over here,
if it's verbal.
But the patients with
the right temporal
ones are just fine.
For spatial things, it's
exactly the opposite.
The group that's really impaired
are the patients with
a large right hippocampal
removal, and the people with
the left hippocampal
do just fine.
So we have two separations in
the brain for learning things
in the medial temporal lobes.
Neither the left nor the right
are involved in short-term
memory, short-term memory
lasting only seconds.
The left is important for verbal
long-term memories, and
the right is important for
long-term spatial memories,
which is very consistent with
what we know about left and
right hemispheres for verbal
and spatial knowledge.
So let me say a word more about
how we think about the
organization of memory, and
we'll come back to this chart.
So we're talking here, so far,
about what people call
declarative or explicit
memory.
You study some material,
you get tested on it.
What did you study?
And people sometimes make
a difference between
two kinds of things.
So episodic memory might
be if I ask you--
OK, I need a volunteer
in your seat.
It's really easy, this one.
OK, thanks.
I saw some people getting
ready to go.
Well, OK.
OK, what did you have for
breakfast this morning?
And you don't have to answer
honestly if its embarrassing.
You can just give
us a standard--
(LAUGHING) I'm not
looking to make--
yeah.
AUDIENCE: Cereal.
PROFESSOR: Cereal.
How about you?
AUDIENCE: What?
AUDIENCE: Yogurt.
PROFESSOR: Yogurt.
Cereal and yogurt.
Two excellent healthy answers.
OK.
So now I'm going to ask you--
if I could ask you first.
How many feet in a yard?
AUDIENCE: Three.
PROFESSOR: Excellent.
OK.
And now I'm going to ask
you, when and where
did you learn that?
OK?
And you might go,
I don't know.
I just learned it.
Right?
Or if I ask you, capital
of France.
AUDIENCE: Paris.
PROFESSOR: Paris.
Excellent answer.
When was the shocking moment
when this was revealed to you?
When you said, I'll never
trust the world again--
yes.
Who knows, right?
So what you're learning is,
episodic memory is memory for
specific events, like what I did
last night, what I had for
breakfast, specific
time and place.
Semantic memory is what we could
call generic memory.
We know lots of things about
the world, but we might not
know when or where we learned.
So that's a distinction
psychologists find useful to
think about.
So how about in HM?
We said he can't remember
digits, or faces,
or things like that.
How about generic memory?
So here's an experiment that
I was involved in, where we
said-- because there
were some debates
about this at the time.
So we gave HM a multiple choice
test where he saw words
or phrases that entered the
language after the onset of
his amnesia.
So we thought he wouldn't learn
them, but we didn't know
for sure, from just everyday
experience.
And by the way, I should tell
you, he watched tons of
television.
What his experience was like
watching television is an
interesting question.
You should be thinking now about
questions you want to
ask about HM.
In a moment, I'll come
back to that.
But look at-- so, he has four
choices for the word
amniocentesis, including the
correct one, but he picks "an
infectious inflammatory
disease of the
intestines." apartheid?
In front of him is the correct
answer, two other answers, and
he picks, "the separation of
young cows that have not yet
given birth to calves."
Boat people? "People who cater
bon voyage parties," which is
completely the wrong--
Brainwash, "a fluid that
surrounds and bathes the
brain." Granola, "a portable
keyboard wind instrument."
Software, "expensive clothing
made of a soft, twilled
fabric."
What's going on with him?
Are these, like, crazy
weird answers?
Or how would you-- what do we
think is going on with him?
Why is he picking these?
The other one is right
in front of him.
What's he doing?
AUDIENCE: Looking at
words he knows.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
He's doing what teachers
teach you in school.
Take apart the word into
its parts, right?
And so he goes, software, soft
clothes that you wear.
But what does that mean?
He's missed, in every sense,
the advent of computers and
software in the world.
The idea, the concept,
the words--
it's as if it didn't exist,
because in 1953, although
software existed, it wasn't
a very popular concept.
Most people didn't know about
the concept of that.
In 1953--
the way we looked at these,
these were not words that were
in the dictionary
in the 1950s.
So now, what would you like to
know about a man like HM?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So obviously he
couldn't remember something
that happened two hours ago,
but if you're having a
conversation with him, would he
not remember what you guys
were talking about?
Or could he remember the context
of the conversation?
PROFESSOR: Right.
So you're saying, he wouldn't
remember something two days
ago, but you're talking
with him.
What's that like?
Right?
So let me give you
one experimental
thing and then an exper--
so one experiment they did is
they left him with something
like six numbers, well within
the span, and said, remember
these numbers.
And it could be, you know, 1,
2, 3, 4, 5, 6-- well, that
wouldn't work so well.
2, 4, 6, 8, 9.
They leave the room
for 15 minutes.
They come back in.
He's an excellent subject.
He's going, 2, 4, 6, 8, 9.
2, 4, 6, 8, 9.
What were the numbers?
They go, that's excellent.
Was there any trick you
did to do that?
Or did you just--
And he'd go, oh, oh, oh.
What were the numbers?
As soon as a thought is out
of the forefront of
his mind, it's gone.
So, yeah.
He would not recognize us, and
we spent many hours with him.
A striking thing, which was
amazing at first and then
sometimes irksome if you worked
with him-- and he was a
delightful guy--
was that he would tell you
a story from his past.
And he didn't have a huge array
of stories, because they
were all from a long time ago.
And he would tell you about
a gun collection he had.
And he would tell he had three
guns, and they had this
property and that property.
He'd finish the story, and if
you just stayed quiet for a
moment, he would forget that he
told you the story, but it
would be vaguely on his
mind because he
just told it to you.
And he would say to you, hey,
did I tell you about my gun
collection?
And he would tell you, almost
verbatim, the same story.
You'd just wait a moment.
He forgot that he told you this
story, but it's slightly
on his mind because you
just told you it.
And he goes, hey, did
I tell you my--
he could tell you this until you
could bear it no longer.
So it was kind of amazing
how short his
short-term memory was.
Without this part of the brain,
it's just a few seconds.
His conversations were
OK, but I would
call them pretty shallow.
I don't know how to put it.
You know, when you talk with
somebody and you're on the
phone, and they're
doing something
else, and you can tell--
for him it was a little
bit like that.
He was-- so, good social
convention.
He would smile.
He would chat with you.
But if what you were talking
about depended on remembering
something from three sentences
ago in any detail, gone.
Just seconds, unless he's
practicing and practicing and
practicing without doing
anything else.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So he did have
the capability to learn
procedurally.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
We're going to come to that.
So the question is, did he
ever learn-- he had other
kinds of learning that
were amazingly
completely normal in him.
Procedural memory, you're
absolutely right.
And we'll come to that just
in about 20 minutes, OK?
Exactly right.
And if I don't answer that well,
make me do that again.
OK?
But yeah.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Was he able to
remember that he couldn't
remember things?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Really good question.
Was he able to remember that he
couldn't remember things?
Yes, he knew he had
a bad memory.
So now the question is, in what
sense did he know he had
a bad memory?
Like, I know I can't draw very
well, amongst many other
things I can't do very well.
But if you talked to him,
he'd say, yeah, I
don't have a good memory.
But he's looking at you, and
he's going, like, I don't know
where I am, who you are,
or what I'm doing.
Everything is vague, for
many, many years.
I must have bad memory.
Like, you would too, like
a science fiction movie.
You woke up, you didn't know who
you were, where you were,
what you were doing, and you
can't remember anything except
from the most distant past.
You'd go, something is not
good with my memory.
But you're smart, so you
would know that.
What I don't know is if you woke
him up at 2 AM and you
said, HM, how's your memory?
I don't know if he'd go, well,
I'm a famous amnesic, of
course it's terrible.
I don't know if he knew it as
a fact, like we might know
about what we're good and not
good at, or he just knew it by
constantly being aware that he
didn't know anything he ought
to know via memory.
Does that make sense?
Anything else about--?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: How does one explain
scientific consent to--?
PROFESSOR: Oh, this is good.
It's a very interesting
question.
Informed consent.
So technically he was conserved
by the state once
his family had passed away.
But, you know, his intelligence
was fine, so you
had to be a little bit careful
to do it right.
But you could tell him, we're
going to do an experiment.
We're going to test your
memory for words.
Is that OK with you?
And he'd say yes.
Of course, if you had him read
a 12-page document, by the
time he got to page 12-- but you
could talk him through it.
His intelligence was fine.
You could worry about the
edges, if there--
so I think the investigators
felt an extra ethical thing,
also, not to ask him to do
anything that a person
might say no to.
He was a wonderful participant,
but it was an
extra responsibility for the
reason you're saying.
AUDIENCE: Does that mean he
was happy all the time?
PROFESSOR: Was he happy
all the time?
Excellent question.
He was a very sort of mellow--
yeah.
Well, you could think for a
moment whether having no
memory would make you
happy or sad.
So he couldn't hold a job.
He couldn't sustain a human
relation because he would
never know he'd met
you before.
So, those are things we often
think of as pretty big in our
happiness, the kind of the
work we do, in some broad
sense, and the people
we relate to, right?
And those were all
gone for him.
On the other hand, he didn't
exactly realize that.
He didn't realize
he didn't work.
He didn't realize he didn't
have relations he might be
expected to have, because he'd
forget that about as fast as
he could think about it.
So I--
he was kind of a very, I would
say, mild, happy person.
So there's three possibilities
that crossed my head.
And scientifically, we can
never figure them out.
One of them is, maybe just
he was that way.
I mean some people are just
mellow and happy, right?
They don't have--
without amnesia.
Second possibility is-- he had
removed, also, the amygdala.
We'll talk about that
later in the course.
That's a structure that's pretty
important for some
aspects of emotion
and feeling.
So that could have
been relevant.
The third one is, but this is
kind of getting to your
question, which was just--
intuitively, I feel like this.
Again, this is not science
but is just a feeling.
That what makes us mostly
sort of happy or sad?
For me, it's mostly relatively
recent things that went well
or didn't go well, or things
I'm sad about recently, and
things on my horizon.
Things I'm worried about, or
things I'm looking forward to.
And you guys might be different,
but I don't get
that worked up these days
about second grade.
At the time I'm sure it was
pretty emotional about it.
So if you think about him, he
doesn't remember anything
recent that was good or bad.
He doesn't remember anything
coming up that's interesting,
or threatening, or risky,
or unpleasant.
So he lives in this
constant now.
You know, people tell you,
live in the moment.
Nobody could have lived more
in the moment than he did.
It's impossible to live more
in the moment when the
previous moment you can
consult is from
30, 40 years ago.
So, yeah, he was pretty happy,
and a pretty pleasant guy.
Essentially, I don't think most
of us want that life,
although he's probably happier
than many people who have all
their memories.
One thing he's the opposite
of, just to remind you--
we talked about it now, but just
to make it clear-- it's
the opposite of television
amnesia.
What happens in soap operas and
murder movies or comedy
shows when they get bonked
on the head?
Television amnesia.
They forget who they are and
where they came from, right?
And then they marry their worst
enemy or something like
this, to make the story
go forward.
That's television amnesia.
But after that, they're
kind of fine, right?
They're kind of operating
but they just
forgot where they come--
that we never see after
brain injuries.
We never see a person who
forgets who they are but gets
around fine in the world.
HM is the opposite.
He remembers stuff from
before, but he
can't learn new things.
Opposite of TV amnesia.
Any other questions about HM?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: As he got older,
could he recognize
people from his past?
AUDIENCE: Yes, and let me talk
a little bit about that.
If I don't answer that,
let me know.
So let me talk about this.
This sort of touches on this,
loss of already-known
information.
And if I don't answer you
well, just put your
hand up again, OK?
So it's easy to test learning
new things, because you can
give somebody something in the
laboratory and you see
if they learn it.
Knowing things they should
have known from
before is much harder.
Different people know different
things, in the past.
So here's how they'd test it.
And here's a thing that people
have discovered, which is
people are pretty
unknowledgeable, mostly, about
faces of people who
were famous at the
time they were famous.
But if you're, like, 20, you
don't know people who were
famous before you were born.
Mostly.
There's some exceptions.
So they'd take faces from
different decades, and they'd
show you them and they'd ask
you, do you know who this is?
So do you know who this is?
This is Lindbergh.
Frank Sinatra.
Bob Hope.
Does that name even
ring a bell?
I know.
This is totally--
however old you are is totally
how you do on this test.
Lyndon Baines Johnson, president
of the United States
after Kennedy.
Douglas MacArthur,
the general.
This, you might.
Richard Nixon.
McCarthy, as in McCarthyism.
Golda Meir.
Elvis.
OK now.
If you--
pretend you became amnesic.
You became amnesic.
Pretend you're old enough to
become amnesic in 1990.
This is if you're feeling--
would you know this
face, in 1990?
Let's say 1980.
Let's make it simple.
1980?
No.
Would you know this face?
OK.
But you know them now.
So that tells you that you can
put faces to decades, roughly.
You know, 1980, only Barack
Obama's family knew Barack
Obama's face, right?
And now we all do.
Temporally limited retrograde
amnesia.
So this is how well you do--
higher is better--
in decades.
In 1960, here's HM.
So here's faces that were famous
in the '20s, '30s, and
'40s, before he became amnesic,
and he's pretty normal.
These are public faces.
And then he's terrible
for the '50s and
'60s, after his amnesia.
So his memory for faces from
the past is pretty normal.
His memory for faces from the
onset of his amnesia forward
is terrible.
Is that OK?
Does that answer your
question reasonably?
But here's another really
weird thing that people
observed in many cases, which is
kind of hard to understand,
but it's been observed
in many cases.
So here's another patient.
He was a bus driver
in Washington, DC.
He moved to work in a drugstore
in Boston, then a
mattress factory in Boston.
Then he was hospitalized at the
Boston VA in November 1965
with a huge hematoma on the
right temporal parietal-- a
big bleeding.
And he was pretty aphasic
and stuporous.
He couldn't answer questions.
In a month, digit span, his
short-term memory returns.
He states the date as
approximately something like
September 1965.
He has a severe anterograde
amnesia.
For example, he fails to learned
the names of the
nurses he sees every day.
But when asked-- this is
the striking thing.
When asked, where do you live?
He says, I live in Washington,
with certainty, as if he lost
all these memories
from before.
By March, he starts to learn
the nurses' names.
He's recovering his
memory capacity.
He couldn't remember that he'd
moved to Boston, but he
doesn't fight the idea that
he lives in Boston.
Then he remembers that he
worked at a drugstore.
Then he remembers that he worked
in a mattress factory.
And by the time that he's
discharged, it's only the last
24 hours before he went into the
hospital that he's lost.
So two things.
There's a coupling between the
anterograde amnesia and the
retrograde amnesia.
He can't learn new things,
but he lost old things.
And as the anterograde amnesia
resolves, the retrograde
amnesia resolves, in some sense,
in temporal order.
It's really odd, but it's been
observed many times.
So there is some link between
what the hippocampus does and
memory for the past.
Now in some ways, it's really
hard to study these things in
detail in a patient like HM.
But some other patients give
us another perspective.
Although every one of these
examples is not quite perfect.
Here's patients who undergo
treatment for depression with
electroconvulsive therapy.
And appropriately--
in movies like One Flew Over
the Cuckoo's Nest, wrongly
used electroconvulsive
therapy is wrong.
For some patients with severe
depression who fail to respond
to medications and who have
suicidal ideation--
literally attempt to take their
lives or talk a lot
about it in a believable way
to family and physician--
electroconvulsive therapy
can be very helpful.
It's a hard choice to make,
and a complicated one.
Here's what happens.
Patients typically go-- and it
varies-- but they go in for
the electroconvulsive therapy.
And nowadays, it's done,
typically, only in the right
hemisphere.
In this study, done some
years ago around
1972, it was bilateral.
They put electrodes on both
sides of the brain.
They passed current and they
induced a seizure.
And they do that something
like every second day for
about 10 days.
It's a very aggressive form
of treatment, certainly.
But for some patients, the
depression just lifts, and
they're no longer talking about
taking their lives.
So for some people it seems to
work when other things don't.
During the course of the
treatment, these patients
develop and anterograde
amnesia.
They become HM-like.
While they're in the hospital,
they become HM-like.
They can't learn new things.
They forget the nurses.
You can test them formally.
And so Larry Squire did the
following experiment with
these kinds of patients.
So we don't know that it's the
hippocampus that's the
critical thing in these
patients, but they
look a lot like HM.
And we know that the
hippocampus has
a low seizure threshold.
That's why it occurs so often
as the locus of epilepsy.
So what they did is they
took television shows.
And this is another world than
you can possibly imagine.
I grew up in a world where there
were basically three
television stations.
And you're feeling sad for
me already, right?
And so everybody knew
what was on those
three television stations.
But they took shows that weren't
very successful, that
were on for one season only.
So they weren't super popular,
but a lot of people saw them.
And there were only
three television
networks and stations.
So now what they did is they
tested them on these events or
other things like that before
they had ECT-- so this is
their knowledge before
they had ECT.
Of course they remember recent
things, 1971, better than
stuff from years ago.
We all do.
But the striking thing is that
when these patients got ECT,
during the course of their
amnesia they only lost memory
for TV shows from the
last two years.
They didn't lose
those memories.
These are the very
same patients.
The very same patients before
they got ECT and while they're
getting ECT, they lose memory
only for the last two years of
TV shows and not all
the other ones.
Or the same thing you can do
with famous public events.
So this is what people call a
temporally-limited retrograde amnesia.
It goes back for some years, the
knowledge you already had.
And here's the amazing thing.
When these patients go home,
their memory largely comes
back and so does their knowledge
of the TV shows.
It's as if it's in
their brain.
They don't have access to it,
for the last two years of
information.
But it's still sitting there and
they regain that access.
Two more examples on this.
So here's an example--
because with humans
it's always tough.
So they do the same thing
with monkeys.
With monkeys, they could create
a surgical lesion like
HM and train them on material.
They knew exactly what
they learned.
Here they had the surgery
either 2, 4, 8 or
12, or 8, 16 weeks.
And you can see the monkeys with
the hippocampal damage
were performing poorly if they
learned the material 2 or 4
weeks ago but not 8
or 16 weeks ago.
Again, a temporally-limited
retrograde amnesia.
So we're getting the idea that
the hippocampus is important,
not only for forming
new memories--
and this is kind of wild.
It's still important for you to
remember stuff from a week
ago, a month ago, and
a couple years ago.
And it takes years for your
memory to become independent,
or what people call
consolidated, so that it no
longer depends upon
the hippocampus.
So the hippocampus both is
required to form a new memory,
and it seems like it's necessary
to remember that
memory from months to years,
before that memory becomes
independent of the
hippocampus.
So right now in you, it's as
if you had a neurochemistry
team finishing your memories
from the end of eighth grade.
We're done.
We're moving on to
ninth grade!
Because it takes years for your
hippocampus to no longer
be required to get those
memories that you
acquired years ago.
And the same thing-- they did
these famous faces, like the
ones I showed you before?
So these had to be somewhat
older people.
Here's activation in the 1990s,
if they were looking at
famous faces and the experiment
was done in the
late 1990s.
So recent faces, hippocampus
turned on, but not for '80s,
'70s, or '60s, or
'50s, or '40s.
Again, they said the hippocampus
is required to
retrieve memories that's in
the rest of your brain for
some time period, but then after
much time passes, it's
no longer required.
So this just summarizes
those things.
So now, Tyler, if we
could do the film.
We're going to how you
an amnesic patient.
Most amnesic patients
are like this man.
Very intelligent, very verbal.
Not dramatic, but with terribly
impaired memory.
So last part of the talk is this
idea of memory systems
and procedural memory, the idea
that you're a symphony of
the neural systems that learn
different things.
So your brain is like the
university, right?
Department of Chemistry,
department of Biology,
department of Brain and
Cognitive Science, or Economics.
In you are multiple very
specialized learning circuits
that are good for learning
different things.
So this idea of a memory system,
a particular part of
the brain that has a particular
learning process.
And a key concept in that is,
so far we've been talking
about what people would
normally call memory--
explicit or direct testing.
You know, what did you study?
What year is it?
You're asked directly
to do something.
But another way to show memory
and learning is through
changes in performance
with practice.
So people will sometimes call
the first kind declarative
memory, where you directly have
conscious memory about
facts and episodes.
You know that you know
something, or
that something occurred.
And then the other kind, we'll
talk about now, procedural
memory, accessible only through
performance and
knowing how.
Now with these kinds of skill
learning or procedural memory,
we see how people get better
when they practice.
Getting better is a change in
your behavior that's learned
and a change in your brain
that performs.
This is for your performance.
So here's the experiment that
was the original one Brenda
Milner did with HM,
where you have to
trace a star in a mirror.
You see your hand in a mirror,
but you don't have direct view
of your hand.
Have any of you done something
like this for some odds and
ends reason?
Anybody?
Sometimes--
do I see a hand?
No.
OK.
It's surprisingly hard.
The horizontals and verticals
are pretty easy.
The diagonals, as you
move your hand, you
go, oh, it's no problem.
I just reverse everything.
And you see your hand just
drift the wrong way.
And you go, OK, no,
no, no, no.
I just have to go 45
degrees difference.
I can do it.
And you're controlling your
hand, but then you move again
and it still goes
the wrong way.
And so at first, you make
lots of mistakes.
We understand this because you
have such automaticity between
what you see and how you move
all the time, that the mirror
reverse, you have to overcome
that automatic relationship.
So at first you make a lot of
mistakes and move slowly.
You practice, and
you get better.
Here's the remarkable thing
with-- so here's HM.
Each of these dots is the next
time he does it consecutively.
He gets better from doing
it over and over again.
That's not a shock.
Here's the shock.
He comes the next day, he keeps
the learning he had and
he gets better.
He comes in day three,
he keeps learning.
Now for him, a day is like
infinity, for memory.
When he comes in the room, he
says, what do I do with this?
You'd go, well, we did
it the last two days.
Don't you know?
He said, no, I have no idea.
Have you done this before?
No.
You can give him multiple choice
of different things he
might have done.
He'll pick the wrong thing.
When you come in on day three
and you're this good, you're
pretty proud.
In fact, vain.
You're going, like,
I can do this.
I'm awesome.
Just let me at it.
Because you know that
you did it.
You know how good you are
through practice.
He has no idea, but his learning
is entirely normal.
Not just better than
you'd think?
Just as good as you.
So a memory system in his brain,
different than the
hippocampus, has kept that
memory, uses that memory.
And the amazing thing is that
this means that that's also
true in you, as far as we
understand these things.
When you learn a physical or
mental skill, a lot of it is
learned in a way that has
nothing to do with your memory
that you learned the skill.
It's all by doing.
And it doesn't depend
on the hippocampus.
And some years later, I did
this again a little bit.
Here's his performance first,
second, third day, a week
later, two weeks later,
and a year later.
Complete retention for a man who
can forget within moments.
A year later, a skill.
He forgets that he did it
ever within moments.
So another kind of task that
people do-- same idea.
A motor skill you can lose, it's
called rotary pursuit.
There's a disc like this that
revolves around a platter that
turns pretty fast.
Your job is to maintain
contact between--
this was sort of sad before
video games, right?
This is about as interesting
as 1940s games got.
It was whizzed around, and it's
fast enough that it's not
easy to do.
And at first your hand goes off
it, but with practice you
get really good at revolving
with a rotating disc.
And HM and patients like him
learned that very well.
Another motor skill.
So who's bad at learning this?
Which part of the brain is your
instrument for learning
skills through practice?
So our best evidence comes
from patients with a very
difficult disease called
Huntington's disease.
It's a genetic rare disease.
Its onset is in the
30s or 40s.
These patients get severe motor
problems and movement
problems, and then, over
time, cognitive ones
and psychiatric ones.
There's no treatment for it.
So this is the caudate withering
away in a patient
with Huntington's disease
compared to a healthy
person's, post mortem.
Or if you look at an MRI, here's
your basal ganglia.
Here's the withered away basal
ganglia in the patients with
Huntington's disease.
And there's a brief--
can we do, Tyler-- there's a
brief video of a patient with
early-stage Huntington's
disease.
So it's not the most severe
problem they have, but when
they do one of these motor
kinds of tasks--
here's normal typical people
learning a motor task, getting
better on it.
It's good to be high
on this graph.
Here's the patients with
Huntington's disease showing
no learning at all.
And this is a test
that an amnesic
patient would learn normally.
So very convincing-- and you
could say, well, if they have
a motor problem, they're not
going to get a motor skill.
So one thing they do is they
make the platter turn very
slowly, so at the beginning
they're doing just as well.
And they still show no
learning at all.
So there's a lot of other
evidence sparked by this that
just shows that the basal
ganglia is an instrument
that's essential for us to
learn physical or motor
skills, perceptual skills,
and a variety of
cognitive skills as well.
Things where we practice,
practice, practice to become
excellent--
basal ganglia is doing a lot
of that work for you.
The last kind of learning I'll
talk to you about, and the
last disease, is a sort of odder
form of learning called
repetition priming.
It's a change in performance
because of
something you did recently.
And if I give you a concrete
example, it'll feel better.
So here's one of
many examples.
Imagine you study a list of
words like stamp, landmark,
speak, clock.
You study a list of
words like these.
I can give you an explicit or
declarative memory test.
What words did you see?
You'd recall them.
Or which word did you see, that
we'd do multiple choice.
That's regular memory that
we know depends on the
hippocampus.
I can also give you weird test
like this, which says, tell me
the first word you think of
that starts with STA.
Now if you have good memory,
you'll go, do you want me to
give you stamp?
Is that the point?
And you go, no, no, no.
And they go, oh, it's
a Freudian thing.
You want to know some weird
things I'm gonna think of.
And you go, no, no, no.
Just tell me the first word
you think of, OK?
And you can give many answers
that are all perfectly fine.
You can give stall, stand,
staccato, star, many STA
words, and all of
them are fine.
That's all you have to do.
But if you saw stamp, one
particular completion of this,
about 10 minutes ago, you're
biased or primed to come up
with that word.
Not all the time, but much
more than by chance.
A recent experience biases you
to behave in a certain way.
And here's the remarkable
thing.
When you do this experiment with
HM, if you just had the
list of words and you
wait about 20
seconds, here's your recall.
Now you're not surprised that
recall from a healthy person
is about seven words, right?
You tried that yourself.
HM, sadly, has no score
because he always
goes, like, what list?
So no recall.
Multiple choice recognition,
where there are three choices,
here's typical people,
HM about chance.
The probability above chance--
that you give stamp as
the completion to
STA if you saw stamp--
if I showed you star, probably
you'd give star.
The specific word you
saw 10 minutes ago?
Perfectly the same in HM as
normal control subjects.
He was just as influenced by
that word he saw 10 minutes
ago as you are, to give
you that answer.
So this got people very excited,
because they said,
now we can experimentally and
scientifically study something
that Freud talked about as a
very vague idea, the cognitive
unconscious.
He's not conscious that he saw
a list of words 10 minutes
ago, but it's making him
choose to behave in
a certain way now.
Now you have both things
in you, as far as
we understand it.
You can both remember you saw
the word list, but if you
switch your thinking a little
bit, your behavior a little
bit, the unconscious system gets
into the driver's seat.
Because the people with good
memory were giving stamp often
but no more or less than HM.
So unconscious.
So what part of the brain does
this kind of memory?
And our insight to that comes
from Alzheimer's disease.
So HM's kind of amnesia
is extremely rare.
Huntington's is quite rare.
Alzheimer's is tragically
common.
In fact, they went to East
Boston, the area near Logan,
and knocked on doors
of people's homes.
Not people in nursing homes.
At home.
And they estimated--
and there's debates about
this back and forth.
But about half the people over
85 who answered the door
qualify for diagnosis of
Alzheimer's disease.
About half over 85.
There's debates about this.
There's debates about whether
all of us would get it if we
lived long enough.
But as American society gets
older, as us baby boomers all
move into our '60s, '70s, and
'80s, there's going to be a
heck of a lot of people around
with Alzheimer's disease.
And some of you have probably
experienced this, with
grandparents if nothing else.
It's a very devastating disorder
for the patient, for
the spouse or family.
It's a very challenging
disorder.
So what is Alzheimer's
disease?
Well behaviorally,
it's an insidious
and progressive dementia.
Dementia means, unlike HM, it's
many losses of abilities.
Unlike HM.
HM had his surgery
one day, boom.
That was it.
Alzheimer's starts very
slowly and gets worse
and worse over time.
The biggest problem early on
is memory, the most common
problem but over time,
language, thinking,
concentration, spatial thinking,
sometimes mood and
personality, all of these
get altered over time.
In the brain when you look at
the changes, you see that the
changes occur especially in the
hippocampal region-- so
that's why the memory
problem is like HM--
and also in some other parts
of the cortex, but not so
much, for example, in basal
ganglia, that we just spoke
about as important for
procedural memory.
Here's a control brain and
equal-aged Alzheimer's brain.
The reason why these gyri, this
whole side widened is
because of widespread neuronal
shrinkage or death.
And what's happening inside the
brain, when you look at
post mortem, there's sort of
neurofibrillary tangles and
plaques that are associated
with the diseases.
The tangles are something
about the
cells that have died.
The plaques are thought to be
maybe part of the process that
leads to the disorder, but
there's a debate about
that to this day.
And if you look, on post mortem,
where the tangles are,
the tangles up here, you can see
they're most dense in the
hippocampus or near the
hippocampus, like HM.
And so that's why we think so
many patients with Alzheimer's
have an HM-like memory
problem and then more
problems after that.
So here's a healthy person
top of the brain.
Here's the left and right
hippocampus in an 81-year-old.
And here in an 80-year-old
Alzheimer's patient, the
hippocampus has withered away,
both sides of the brain,
bilaterally.
So one more brain perspective
on this.
This is a SPECT scan, that just
shows you where there's
blood flow and metabolism.
Top of the brain, bottom
of the brain.
Here's the insides of the
temporal lobes in a healthy
elderly adult.
Look how much worse--
this is HM.
He looks pretty good, right?
You have to look really hard to
see that the hippocampus is
missing because it's such
a small structure.
And here's an early-stage
Alzheimer's patient.
Lots of the tissue is there, but
a lot of-- you know, it's
not functioning because there's
so much damage.
Here's the medial temporal lobes
but also cortical areas
that are compromised.
OK, again.
Not their biggest problem, but
in terms of thinking about
different parts of the
brain and what parts
of memory they do--
So these are amnesic patients,
including HM, Alzheimer's
patients, and green
in controls.
So recall of the list, what
words were on the list,
explicit memory bad in the
two patient groups.
Recognition pretty poor.
Word stem completion, the kind
of thing that we said is
completely normal in
HM, that's impaired
in Alzheimer's disease.
So we think that kind of
priming depends on the
neocortex, the part of the brain
that's also injured in
Alzheimer's.
Because we know it doesn't
depend on the hippocampus,
because the patients with
hippocampus-only damage are fine.
So we end up with a picture
like this of something on
memory systems.
For explicit or declarative
memory, from patients with
amnesia, we know it depends on
the medial temporal lobe.
Left, verbal; right, spatial.
For skill learning, anything you
practice many times to get
better at, we know from
Huntington's disease, that
depends on the basal ganglia.
For kinds of priming, recent
experience altering something
about brain organization,
Alzheimer's disease, we know
from that that it's likely
mediated by the neocortex.
These are from patient studies,
but the imaging
studies are very well aligned
with these things.
So we think it's true not only
of patients, but of you, in
terms of the instruments
of your brain.
So now we have not only
episodic memory
and semantic memory.
We talked about procedural
memory.
We talked about priming.
I didn't talk about conditioning
today, but we've
talked about that before.
So I have two more slides
to add on conceptually.
So in what sense was Karl Ashley
right or wrong when he
said memory's all
over the brain?
Here's how we think
about it now.
We think he was right that all
of your brain is learning.
Practically all of your
brain is plastic.
It changes with experience.
But different parts
of your brain are
learning different things.
The basal ganglia is
learning how to
be skilled at something.
The neocortex, how to gain
knowledge and shift your
representation of knowledge,
like in priming.
The medial temporal lobe on the
left is learning verbal
facts, and the right
is nonverbal
facts or spatial facts.
So all of your brain is
learning, but it's learning
different things.
And in that sense we end up with
this metaphor that-- you
know, just like there's
a string section and a
percussion section or something
like that, in you,
there's all these different
instruments that are highly
tuned in the way they're
organized to learn all the
different things you learned.
They're all pretty useful
instruments to have.
And without these patients and
the imaging studies, we
wouldn't have known that.
You would be like the Martian.
One instrument?
A thousand instruments?
Well, we know there's multiple
ones, and we know pretty much
which structures are
essential for them.
Thanks.